Ninja mientras la comunidad
lgbtiq más se enfrenta a un hito en el
reconocimiento de sus derechos el
Ministerio de Justicia remitió una
petición al tribunal supremo
manifestando su objeción al matrimonio
entre personas de mismo sexo el
documento fue revisado por la agencia de
noticias reuters el Ministerio de
Justicia cree que aunque pueda haber
varias formas de relaciones en la
sociedad el reconocimiento legal del
matrimonio es para las relaciones
heterosexuales y el estado tiene un
interés legítimo en mantenerlo así la
convivencia en pareja y las relaciones
sexuales entre personas del mismo sexo
no son equivalentes con el concepto de
India de unidad familiar entre marido
mujer e hijos cinco años después de
despenalizar las relaciones homosexuales
el tribunal supremo de India escuchará a
varias personas que solicitan el
reconocimiento oficial del matrimonio
entre personas del mismo
sexong y sufrió chacra bortti están
entre los demandantes
en 2021 pero su Unión no está
oficialmente reconocida lo que dificulta
su vida cotidiana
somos pareja desde hace más de 10 años
Somos las personas más importantes en la
vida del otro Sin embargo a los ojos de
la ley no somos nadie solo somos
extraños
mañana si me pasa algo y estoy en el
hospital y Alguien tiene que tomar
decisiones médicas él no tendría derecho
a hacerlo a ojos de la ley si los
demandantes se imponen India sería el
segundo país asiático después de Taiwán
en reconocer el matrimonio entre
personas del mismo sexo